well Delta Airlines says that it will
vigorously oppose a federal lawsuit
filed by a passenger who alleges that
she was sexually assaulted during her
flight Delaney Lou claims she was
molested by another passenger as she
slept she says he was allowed to get off
the plane scot-free last year the FBI
received 63 cases of sex assaults on
flights that's up from 38 in 2014
Jamie yuccas spoke with Lou in an
interview you'll only see on CBS this
morning
I'm like get up get up I'm like you what
are you doing touching me I'm like what
is your problem like oh my god somebody
help me and I started bawling and
Delaney Lou had just fallen asleep on
her Delta flight in June when she says
the man sitting next to her placed his
hand down her pants and exposed himself
it's very violating that's how I felt
you know it's like it's just a piece of
meat
Lou a 23 year old clothing designer says
she ran crying to the flight attendants
in the back of the cabin I was shaking
and I'm like this guy just had his hands
in my pants I don't know him he's a
stranger like he can you please help me
she said to me we're gonna make a report
don't worry we got you you're gonna be
safe straight words from her mouth Lou
was moved to another seat
she says she was the first passenger
allowed off the plane when it landed at
Los Angeles where she was met by Delta
customer service representatives I said
where's the police I'm like you guys
still haven't called the police I was
like what is wrong with you guys
so from your vantage point he just
walked off the plane and away he went
yeah Luke also says he was visibly drunk
when he boarded the plane in Minneapolis
but flight attendants still served him
alcohol I'm like dang hair he smelled
like so much I'll call how much is he
gonna drink how many drinks do you think
he had there was about six to eight Lou
filed a federal lawsuit in Tennessee
claiming Delta was negligent by over
serving the passenger Delta knew or
should have known its actions could lead
to harm to a passenger including a
sexual assault do you feel that the
flight attendants didn't believe you to
be honest that didn't even run through
my head I just think that they just
didn't do their job a delta spokesman
told CBS this morning customer safety is
its top priority and it does not
tolerate the harassment or assault of
passengers but the airline disputes lose
version of events after deplaning miss
Lu first informed a delta agent that she
had been improperly touched on the leg
by another passenger the spokesman said
Delta then immediately reported the
incident to local law enforcement for
their handling and our understanding is
the matter was not pursued according to
the police report Lu said she woke up
with the man's hand on her right outer
thigh above the knee it does not mention
he sexually assaulted her or exposed
himself he talked to the police there
and then the FBI opened up an
investigation and found that they
couldn't corroborate any of the story
and they closed it I know it sounds
weird but having to explain what
happened to me to another man
was just III couldn't do it Lu claims
she was too embarrassed at the time to
go into the details with the male police
officer she received a two hundred
dollar travel voucher for her ordeal
Lois suing Delta for six million dollars
in damages there are a lot of people
that could come out and say oh she just
wants money from Delta yeah no that's
not the case I mean I'm I'm very
well-off myself it's not about the money
it's about doing the right thing for CBS
this morning
Jamie yuccas to stay at California Delta
Airlines also told us its employees are
trained to monitor passenger drinking
and behavior and take specific steps
when handling disruptions such as
harassment assault and intoxication that
includes separating passengers and
alerting law enforcement before the
plane lands